Britain and the European Union may be in
for a messy divorce
Britain's exit or bricks it from one of
the world's most powerful trading bloc's
will happen if Brits vote to leave in a
national referendum on June 23rd
polls show the brexit vote could go
either way so here's how we got to this
situation camp that wants to leave the
EU are the so-called Euroskeptics they
kept the UK from adopting the euro when
it was launched in 1999 nowadays they're
more worried about the surge of
emigration the UK gets about 500 people
added to its population every day since
EU citizens have the freedom to live in
any country they choose leaving the
block is the only sure way to stem the
flow of people arguing to stay in is
Prime Minister David Cameron he
negotiated new terms to the UK's EU
membership including some reassurances
for London's financial industry and the
right to restrict welfare payments to
migrants he says a breakup would be an
economic disaster Europe accounts for
nearly half of the UK exports and he
says a brexit would create a decade of
uncertainty for financial markets
investment and the wider economy the
debate is whip lashing markets and has
sent the pound tumbling now here's the
argument those pushing for a brexit say
the EU has more from a free trade zone
into a super state that's eating away at
Britain's national sovereignty the vote
will likely come down to two issues the
economic risks of an exit versus concern
about a flow of immigrants that can't be
stopped
whichever way the vote goes Britain's
long love/hate relationship with the EU
will rumble on
you